The Joe Rogan Experience I just watched
uh Joachim Phoenix in Joker and he's
he's a very charismatic actor and I was
thinking well God because he carried
that whole movie on on single-handedly
it's a dark dark movie and it has to do
with resentment this man who was forced
to be nice by his mother yeah you know
who turns out to be absolutely crazy and
abused him like mad when he was a kid
and and then he becomes this role model
for the dissemination of complete
catastrophe into the entire Society it's
a story of Cain in part but Phoenix
really carries that and part of the
reason that he does that is because he
creates a compelling character who's
sympathetic like he can be sympathetic
to him because he really did have a hard
life like really hard but Phoenix is an
extraordinarily charismatic person
partly because he's so unbelievably he's
masculine in his features
and carved but he's so graceful
every single thing he does in the entire
movie is a dance like he's conscious of
every single movement he makes every
turn of his head is conscious it's
dance-like and you can't take your eyes
off it and a lot of Stellar performers
had that ability to integrate male
performance had that ability to
integrate that feminine Grace into their
masculine character